infos intox ce soir avec Anthony
Saint-Léger bonsoir Anthony bonsoir
Antoine bonsoir à tous Anthony
vérification ce soir d'une vidéo qui a
largement circulé qui a généré de
nombreux commentaires anti-français
elles montent des véhicules détruits a
priori en Afrique effectivement la
rédaction des Observateurs de France 24
a été interpellé par plusieurs
téléspectateurs et on les en remercie
d'ailleurs l'occasion pour moi de vous
rappeler que si vous avez une un doute
sur une image et bien c'est sur Twitter
que ça se passe vous nous envoyez un
message à cette adresse et nous manquons
pas de vous répondre c'est donc ce qu'on
fait plusieurs téléspectateurs comme
celui-ci qui évoque la vidéo que l'on va
découvrir ensemble dans quelques
instants et qui se posent la question de
savoir s'il s'agit de matériel roulant
détruit par des Français au Burkina Faso
c'est ce qu'a fait aussi cet autre
internaute qui relève c'est ce qui ce
qui se partage à savoir une scène qui se
déroulerait au Mali vous le voyez avec
des commentaires très très antis
français cette vidéo fin du suspense on
va la découvrir ensemble elle est ici
vidéo qui a été partagée
il y a quelques jours maintenant à la
fois sur Facebook sur Twitter dans des
comptes à la fois anglophone arabophone
et francophone 2 minutes 20 d'image ou
vous voyez des pick-up sont détruits par
des engins de démolition il y a aussi
ses hommes en tenue de travail et puis à
la fin de cette vidéo celui qui semble
filmer les images nous dit un beau
travail un goût de Job plus précisément
en anglais alors que disent maintenant
les comptes qui partagent cette vidéo et
bien à chaque fois la France et la cible
pour celui-ci il s'agirait de soldats
français ou en tout cas de Français qui
détruisent leurs outils de travail au
Mali non il serait au Burkina Faso
affirme au contraire celui-ci est plus
précisément dans la mine de percoa une
une légende que l'on retrouve ici aussi
en arabe ou encore ici en anglais
alors Mali ou Burkina Faso Anthony que
sait-on précisément de l'origine de
cette vidéo et bien cette scène à se
déroule au Burkina Faso ça c'est un bon
point plus précisément à la mine de
percoas celle qui est évoquée justement
l'internaute précédent on est à 120 km
de Ouagadougou la capitale burkinabè
cette scène elle est évoquée dans un
communiqué du ministère de l'énergie des
mines et des carrières ministères
burkinabé bien évidemment qui évoque que
le 13 novembre dernier une mission des
gouvernementale a été dépêchée sur place
pour échanger avec les responsables de
la mine on y apprend que six véhicules
ont été détruits des véhicules qui
appartiennent à cette société Nantes to
mining plus précisément à une filiale
burn cut pardon burn cut où on pouvait
avoir d'ailleurs un indice dans la vidéo
puisque il y a sur cette capture d'écran
d'un des pick-up un logo que l'on a
grossi ici et qui se trouve être
justement celui de burn up mais ce ne
sont pas des Français Anthony qui sont
responsables de 7000 en question non
parce que cette mine qui a été ouverte
en 2013 elle appartient en fait à 10 % à
l'état burkinabè et à 90% à cette
société minière une société canadienne
très valide mining dont on voit ici le
logo une société qui fait elle-même
appel à une filiale Nantes to meining
qui elle-même fait appel à un
sous-traitant une société Australine
australienne pardon burn cut qui
exploite donc la mine en question dans
aucun cas il y a un lien entre la mine
de zerkoa en Burkina Faso et des
exploitants français alors le fameux de
l'histoire Anthony est-ce qu'on sait
pourquoi ces véhicules ont été détruits
et bien il y a beaucoup d'insertitudes
on va reprendre le ministère de tout à
l'heure le communiqué du ministère de
tout à l'heure qui évoquait une
destruction des véhicules parce que les
véhicules serait hors d'usage sauf qu'il
n'y a aucun élément qui permet de
confirmer ou d’infirmer d'ailleurs cette
cette thèse d'autant que la société
australienne n'a pas répondu aux
nombreux sollicitations de la rédaction
des Observateurs de France 24 tout comme
d'ailleurs la société nantu mining qui
elle est actuellement en liquidation
judiciaire puisque la mine a fermé après
des inondations meurtrières en avril
dernier l'autre test qui est avancé sur
les réseaux sociaux ce serait que ces
véhicules ont été détruits pour éviter
que des terroristes ne s'ennan pas c'est
une thèse qui laisse plutôt perplexe un
journaliste que l'on a pu contacter un
journaliste burkinabais de mine actu
Burkina Elie Kaboré qui estime que parce
que les zones ou sévissent les journées
les terroristes les djihadistes sont
loin à environ 200 km de cette mine
c'est plutôt peu probable donc beaucoup
d'incertitudes et j'en terminerai
là-dessus vous l'aurez compris mais
aussi surtout des certitudes cette scène
n'a pas eu lieu au Mali
ce n'est pas des français qui en sont
qui en sont les auteurs contrairement à
ce qu'on peut vouloir faire croire les
internautes qui ont surfé sur cette
grogne anti-français qui grandit au
Sahel et notamment depuis
l'officialisation de la Fat varkan la
semaine dernière le 9 novembre par
Emmanuel Macron les grogne dont on parle
régulièrement dans votre chronique
Anthony info intox a retrouvé donc sur
notre site internet france 24.com encore
merci à vous restez avec nous Paris
direct revient dans quelques minutes sur
France 24
[Musique]